What did you get, David?
>> So like before, because this is
an or, as soon as we see that A is true,
we can go ahead and
write down true for all of these.
When A is false,
we just need to evaluate B or C.
When B is true,
we know it's already true.
And then if B is false
we need to look at C.
If C is true, then it's still true,
and if C is false,
then all three are false and
that's the only time it's false.
Over here,
we've moved the parentheses but really,
we're not changing what we do.
We can think of it as stating
at the bottom with C being true.
Anytime C is true,
the entire thing is true.
So C is true here, here, here, and here.
If that evaluates to false,
we need to look at A or B, and so on.
So we end up doing
the exact same process.
>> That's good, David.
And this property is called
the associative property.
The associative property
simply says that we can change
the location of the parentheses here,
A or parentheses B or C,
parenthesis close, has the same value
as A or B parenthesis close or C.
So that we can change
the location of the parentheses.
The same would have been true
if these were both conjunctions.
So if it was A conjunction
parentheses B conjunction C or
A conjunction B, conjunction C,
it would have had the same values.
>> The difference between
these formulas and
the ones we were doing before
are the values of these operators.
Associative property works when
it's both ors or both ands.
Distributive property worked when
there was a mixture of operators.